la moule c'est le principal coquillages
cultivé au canada les moules sont élevés
non pas sur le plancher océanique mais
plus près de la surface de l'eau ce qui
les rend particulièrement vulnérables à
des prédateurs venus dr les canards au
québec ces oiseaux met en péril une
industrie à laquelle de rares
producteurs s'accroche encore
[Musique]
derrière cela se cache une industrie au
potentiel immense tant sur les côtes est
canadienne qu'américaines
mais une industrie freiné dans son
développement à des prédateurs
redoutables les canards demain comme un
fléau la rive quelqu'un qui porte les
l'aspirine il repose tout vaut mieux en
rire mais on ne nourrit des centaines de
milliers de canards au fil des ans
partout sur la côte est les
mytiliculteurs ont sorti l'artillerie
lourde pour se débarrasser de ces
prédateurs
poursuite en bateau
diffuseur sonore épouvantail 12h méthode
d'effarouchement ont été mises à l'essai
mais l'oiseau est malin et ne se laisse
pas facilement berner faire laquelle
adhèrent aux canards se battre contre un
tel total donc quand on nous donnait pas
résultat les pertes annuelles peuvent
atteindre des millions de dollars les 15
maires peuvent s'engouffrer la
quasi-totalité d'une récolte de moore
ont pour une production depuis que les
canards marins sont apparus il ya une
dizaine d'années la production des
règles du jeu a baissé des deux tiers la
rentabilité n'est plus au rendez vous il
pense à abandonner comme d'autres
mytiliculteurs de la région l'ont déjà
fait si on avait comme de grandes
entreprises alors qu'avec avec les plus
grosses productions internes l'automne
puis ces deux entreprises ont fermé
leurs portes après après qu exane et si
on trouve pas de solutions aux canards
moins
c'est s'accroche encore c'est grâce à
cet homme le biologiste marcel fréchette
ce chercheur est peut être la bouée de
sauvetage de la mytiliculture au québec
la base pour la survie d'une moule dans
le milieu littoral c'est de se trouver
une infractuosités du travail une abri
en un abri à ce moment là à devenir
comme
protégé alors un refuge contre ces
prédateurs je me suis dit ça prendrait
un truc comme ça
inspiré par cette façon naturelle que la
moule à de se protéger
il expérimente depuis quelques années un
dispositif qui offre une double
protection
ça commence dès les premiers stades de
vie de l'amour
les naissances de moules sont d'abord
cultivée sur des cordes tressées avec
des nuls là ça va leur donner d agréer
les moules von arx une cachette des vont
pouvoir commencer le cycle de croissance
pire on peut espérer qu'ils soient
entendus assez grande
après après le premier était de
croissance donc après 18 mois pour
qu'ils ne deviennent vulnérables de par
leur taille
o'connor mais au deuxième hiver avant
d'atteindre la maturité les nous ne
suffisent plus pour camoufler les moore
c'est là que le chercheur a été
particulièrement ingénieux en éventant
départ canard dont voici un prototype
essence est ce qu'on voit c'est un
grillage cintrée et dont la fonction est
juste d'empêcher le canard d'avoir accès
à la corde pour des moules donc il faut
que le canard fasse une vrille
descendante quand il plonge autour d'une
ligne d'élevage le fait qu'il y ait ça
ici qui l'empêchent de nager librement
puis de brouter sur la corde donc ça ça
lui compliquer la vie sans murs ou 3 20
ans soutient marcel fréchette
une équipe de chercheurs gaspésien a
aussi eu l'idée de donner une autre
utilité au par canards et de s'en servir
comme support pour la culture des algues
on a eu une idée à la base de faire un
camouflage donc de faire croître les
halles par dessus pour créer un
camouflage plus naturel
ou est-ce que les môles pourraient
potentiellement avoir un meilleur taux
de sauver les plantules d'algues sont
ensemencées sur la cordelette de ce
collector la corde sera déployé en mer
au dessus des moules les algues
formeront éventuellement une forêt sous
marine qui agira comme un mur de
protection contre les kamas tout en
fournissant un revenu supplémentaire aux
mytiliculteurs donc oui c'est vraiment
créer un écran vers le naturel mais
aussi de développer l'esprit de cocoon
tue on ne quitte plus en plus à l'avant
pour avoir deux espèces ensemble qui
peuvent collaborer d'une certaine
manière
à l'île-du-prince-édouard plus important
producteur de moules au pays
la prédation des moules par les canards
existent également
si elle n'a pas la même ampleur c'est
parce que les sites d'élevage se
trouvent le long des côtes et on peut
plus facilement surveiller et éloigner
les canards et désirable
mais les quinze heures de mer n'ont pas
de frontières et le problème est bien
réel aussi sur la côte est américaine où
ils font d'énormes ravages
le même avec son littoral vaste et
rochus compte l'une des plus fortes
populations de camard de mer sur la
planète
certains s'y installent pour l'hiver
d'autres survol lentement la côte
pendant leur migration un ou deux
canards apparaissent ils viennent se
nourrir ils sont une centaine plus
rapidement d'envoi 500 puis bull canal
pour quelques news un pionnier de la
culture des moules au wynn
le choix était simple innover ou mourir
il a misé sur l'innovation et son
innovation la voici un radeau
submersible qui protège les moules des
canards c'est au darling marine center à
l'université du maine que les prototypes
de ce radeau ont été conçus le chercheur
dans amorcé son équipe y ont consacré 25
ans d'efforts il nous montre le premier
modèle un radeau en bois qui comportait
des faiblesses ici de raft moving vous
voyez le radeau bouge beaucoup
alors ça secoue et les moules de haut en
bas
même leurs ados se brise est tellement
le stress sur la structure était grave
quelques années plus tard les chercheurs
parviennent à mettre au point un radeau
plus stable qui résistent mieux aux
fortes vagues pour les éleveurs de
moules du maine les tempêtes sont une
difficulté qui s'ajoute à la prédation
par les canards de mer offshore ce
prototype montre le radeau à 10 pieds de
profondeur avec des vagues de trois
pieds freephone vous voyez les vagues
qui deviennent de plus en plus grosse et
les bouées qui bouche n'est pas le
radeau exactement
on
mais quand une ue au lui pousse le
concept encore plus loin ils
perfectionnent leurs ados submersible
pour le rendre plus résistant encore et
aussi pour protéger la culture des
prédateurs il fallait choisir entre
toutes abandonnées ou développer une
nouvelle technologie pour nous aider à
mieux comprendre quand une ue conduite
au large de french min b où il a
installé son site d'élevage
vous voyez de 20 il y a 6 radeau
submersible il a fallu sept ans de
recherche et développement pour en
arriver à commercialiser notre modèle
deux radeaux ont été remontés à la
surface en prévision de la récolte
mais le fruit de son labeur se cache
sous l'eau les radeaux fait de bois et
d'acier galvanisé flotte littéralement
entre deux eaux il supporte 400 lignes
de culture de moules et pour protéger
ses moules des canards de mer les radios
sont enveloppés d'un filet ils sont
aussi spécialement conçues pour résister
aux intempéries
même aux ouragans
tipi sous les surfaces même avec des
grosses vagues de 5 mètres
le radeau les moules demeure
complètement stable limoux y ne tombe
pas des corps d'enfants et la flore
la technologie et le modèle de
production mises au point par caen
cugnaux rôles ont enfin permis de
stabiliser l'industrie et de rassurer
les mytiliculteurs les moules du monde
sont en forte demande à l'usiné de
transformation
le personnel en sache les mollusques
destiné aux restaurants locaux et aux
marchés de bostens j'adore notre
nouvelle usine c'est tout neuf
la production avec nos radios est
excellente c'est très positif
l'industrie est sur une lancée
on a un produit formidable qui s'est
taillé une place sur le marché et sur la
côte du maine l'aquaculture se développe
plus que jamais
mais la situation n'est pas aussi rose
au québec les efforts n'ont pas encore
permis de relancer l'industrie des
moules qui reste très fragile
les rares producteurs qui survivent
peine à répondre à la demande
pourtant la baie des chaleurs est un
site de choix pour la mytiliculture
soumise aux vents et un système aussi
quant aux chaudes et d'eau froide
elle donne des moules de qualité comme
biologiste je regarde c'est mon blog je
trouve ces des championnes en contrôlant
la problématique des canards y avait
tout ce qu'il faut pour avoir une
industrie qui reprendrait sa vitesse sa
croissance
l'avenir dira si le parquet narrer la
technique de compagnonnage avec les
algues livreront leurs promesses
malgré des échecs répétés le producteur
eric bugeaud reste optimiste il ya
envoyé du monde salue nombreux cadres
restent à régler ce problème là
[Musique]